pounds going resume afraid about who's
gonna pick ever picking him i like woody
he seems nice okay [ __ ] fan
that's not necessary it is [ __ ] he's the
one you want not me no we want your
mother won't be saving you this time
come on
you're under arrest I told you I didn't
do and you've got nothing to worry about
I hope you picked the wrong ranked one
how they picked her I want god damn
goddamn saying ham god damn breakfast
and lunch that's awesome guys there's
just someone uh do anything stupid and
I'll throw you down the witching well
myself I feel bad for tearing off the
arm but he was kind of a dick you know
he called me a dog glass slipper shoe
huh
I'm worried about snow where's she
what's going on here beauty
it's just so much [ __ ] trouble in
this town it's like no one's happy it's
[ __ ] crazy
oh god no no no no
what the [ __ ] we had something very
special
god dammit where's your brother
[ __ ] you give me one good reason I
should tell you anything
serial killer
Oh oh my a serial killer
Oh God and it's one of us white the
woodsman still wall in the streets we've
got to put a lid on this you can't
manage it I'll find someone who can
I found out where she's been staying I
know she's here you must have seen her
what are the two of you hiding
doesn't matter
just some tennis in the background we
can arrange that switching my friend on
friend at the end of the
jeez
oh these are you
god damn it telltale god damn it oh oh
okay now we get to see that if I
actually made the wrong choices or not
and it doesn't look too good so far did
you gain faith your money you and only
that little huh
okay let me let me just talk this for
one minute okay let me just if it was a
boy it was a boy you sure it's [ __ ]
hell wouldn't have given them the money
you all are a bunch of [ __ ] sexes
that's all I'm saying
it's a hot girl oh yeah I better give it
money
I like that I like hey did you tell
Beast the truth about Beauty day I guess
I do make the wrong choices huh okay I
love it let me just talk through this
too I just think if I make a promise to
someone I keep it and if I promise a
girl I'm not gonna tell her and that it
would only make him more worried and I'm
staying out of it I just didn't say
anything now he now the door just
[ __ ] closed and I was like huh
I didn't know he was gonna be a dick
about it I just thought it was gonna
avoid it so I I don't know I'm just
saying how I thought okay most people
went to help Toad before prints it makes
sense like it seemed like whatever was
going on in prints was in that urgent
anyway they should have made it more
interesting like something was going on
at Prince Lauren's maybe then it would
be more interesting to see but seems
like toad was more organ so it makes
sense possibly met toe before we don't
know anything about Prince uh what
happened to Prince Lauren's you did not
prevent Prince Lauren's death oh so that
was just a choice
I didn't seem like I could do that much
plus his girlfriend was dead anyway so
who is your prime suspect
we haven't even know that character how
the [ __ ] 22% select hem 3% selected
Prince Laura 20% you think it's him so
so I guess most people think it's a
woodsman but I'm pretty sure it isn't
who did you arrest when it came down to
the wire you and 70% mature tree leading
getaway so see that just doesn't make
sense why would so many people select
hem but then they would let him go away
interesting god damn it's so interesting
I love this part
seeing it afterwards I love telltale
games I can't wait for episode 2 I'll
try to try to make better choices I
guess I don't know it seems like I made
most of them ones right just these two
in the beginning and like it you bro
said a lot of people said that she lives
even if you give her money which isn't
true so it like whatever honestly um
anyway hope you enjoyed this series I
had a lot of fun playing it live like if
you did so glad you brought into these
story telling games I'll all I love
telltale games they make such awesome
games I'd thank you for making these
awesome games I love it and and I'll see
you in the next one when it comes out I
think it's usually I'm one month in
between write a lot more little less I
don't know it cuts the brofist fathom
haha
yeah [ __ ] his brains out [ __ ] don't
make me do it I don't give a [ __ ]